every two seconds someone in the U.S
needs a blood transfusion but less than
five percent of the population donates
now there's a chance to do two amazing
things at the same time Save a Life and
possibly win Super Bowl tickets here's
how
severe weather and seasonal illness have
left our nation's blood supply
threatened red blood cells lasts for 42
days platelets five days and when there
are challenges like challenging weather
cold weather snow throughout the United
States that makes our blood supply
challenged to really fulfill the needs
of our hospitals the American Red
cross's Regional CEO height arrester
says the call is going out right now to
donors of all blood types but especially
those with type O O positive is the most
common and O Negative the most universal
meaning it can be used for any
individual needing blood those who
donate blood platelets or plasma through
January 31st will be automatically
entered into a national drawing to win a
trip for two for three nights to the
Super Bowl in Arizona it is ticket to
the Super Bowl
um and I understand transportation and
lodging plus 500 gift card as well the
start of the new year one of the most
challenging times to collect enough
blood products but the need doesn't
decrease one in seven patients entering
a hospital will need a blood transfusion
yet only three percent of the public
gives blood you can sign up right now to
give blood and be entered into the Super
Bowl possibility by using the Red Cross
Blood Donor app we've just had great
support with the NFL and many of the
players throughout the years so it is a
great incentive for people to consider
donating blood and our hope is they
donate now and we'll continue to do so
in the future
keep in mind if you can't donate blood
you can always volunteer your time for
the non-profit